Якою буде миротворча місія ООН на Донбасі?
Наскільки чисельною, з якими завданнями та повноваженнями?
Свій проект на Мюнхенській конференції з безпеки
представив колишній генсек НАТО
Андерс Фог Расмуссен
Його ідея – місія під егідою ООН
20  тисяч військовослужбовців
з нейтральних до Росії країн
Про ймовірну участь армії Німеччини
у такій місії в Україні
заявив уповноважений Бундестагу з питань збройних сил Ганс-Петер Бартельс
Якщо йдеться не про окрему
закордонну місію Бундесверу
а про участь в більшому міжнародному контингенті
то саме на це Бундесвер здатний сьогодні
і буде здатний наступного року
Бундесвер налаштований так, щоб завжди бути напоготові для нової місії в новому році.
Згідно з різними пропозиціями до завдань "блакитних шоломів"
можуть входити охорона
400 кілометрів україно-російського кордону
забезпечення миру на 17 тисячах квадратних кілометрів ОРДЛО
чи навіть контроль 500-кілометрової
лінії протистояння
Досвід у Бундесверу для цього є
Зараз Німеччина бере участь
у 13-ти різних закордонних місіях
Наприклад, у Косові військові Бундесверу забезпечують режим припинення вогню
у Лівані – контролюють кордон
у Судані захищають населення від бойовиків
в Малі розвозять гуманітарну допомогу
і допомагають поверненню внутрішніх переселенців
Проте коли йдеться про технічне оснащення Бундесверу
не все так добре
У міноборони ФРН визнають
через брак екіпірування та техніки
сухопутні війська Бундесверу обмежено дієздатні
щонайменше на наступні три роки - до 2021
Не вистачає багато чого
від бронежилетів, наметів, пристроїв нічного бачення і зимового обмундирування
до справних танків і вертольотів
Навіть мастил і запчастин для ремонту недостатньо
Матеріальна ситуація залишається вкрай поганою
а подекуди стала ще гіршою
За остані роки готовність армії в плані забезпечення не лише не покращилась
а ще й має тенденцію до погіршення
Проголошений курс на покращення фінансової
технічної та кадрової складових
можна тільки вітати
але одні лише заяви ситуацію не покращать
Нині Бундесвер налічує трохи більше 170 тисяч осіб
це найменша армія в сучасній історії Німеччини
Донедавна усі країни Європи
скорочували свої військові видатки
після завершення "холодної війни"
багато витрачати на армію
вважалося неактуальним
Але після анексії Криму
та агресії Росії на Донбасі ситуація змінилася
Про незадовільний стан німецької армії
заговорили у зв’язку з участю Бундесверу
в силах швидкого реагування НАТО "Вістря списа"
Та якщо Берліну складно
забезпечити 900 солдатів для проекту Альянсу
то потреби для значно масштабнішої місії на Донбасі
можуть стати неспівмірними
нинішньому потенціалу Бундесверу